it's not easy it's a hard journey but at
the end of the day I feel like it is so
so worth it Tia Mowry opens up about her
divorce from Corey Hardrick and how she
knew it was time to walk away I feel
like I I do have a lot to say last month
the actress announced she and Corey were
calling it quits after 14 years of
marriage writing on Instagram quote
these decisions are never easy and not
without sadness adding that they will
maintain a friendship as they co-parent
the two children they share
eleven-year-old son cree and
four-year-old daughter Cairo family is
so important to me and on Tuesday Tia
revealed when she knew her marriage was
over during a stop by the Today show I
knew when I really started to focus on
my happiness I feel like women we tend
to focus on everybody else's happiness
making sure that everybody else is okay
meaning you know our children
our friends our you know family but at
the end of the day it's about self-love
and when you start to really work on
yourself love yourself know your value
know your worth and then all of a sudden
there's this Awakening Tia adds she was
feeling sadness and the death of two
family members prompted her to look
inward there was just an aha moment in
me where I said you know what you need
to tap in see what's really going on
with your happiness life is short let's
go let's start working on you and really
focusing on what really really matters
here which is at the end of the day your
peace your joy and your happiness E.T
was with Tia shortly after she shared
the news of her split from Corey I have
to be honest with you so overwhelmed by
all of the support and the love that I
have received over the past week or two
um and I'm just so grateful of the
community and just the fans that I have
and the women you know I'm all about
inspiring and encouraging
and I mean the DMS that I have gotten
from so many women that are going
through the same thing and just saying
how they admire my courage and my
strength it I mean it has just been
I feel so blessed and tia has that same
positive outlook reflecting on the end
of her marriage my marriage was a
success I was able to create with Corey
some beautiful amazing children so
what's next for Tia here's what she told
E.T what does this next chapter of life
look like for you
authenticity I think authenticity it
it's very magical when you are living in
your truth and your honesty I feel like
amazing wonderful things happen I mean
there's so many great things that are
happening in my life and I just feel so
grateful
um and blessed
[Music]